- I remember coming home
on night after a big fight
and I run up to the kitchen and I get ice
and my hand's swollen.
Just another day at work.
There was a time in my life
when I said if I don't,
if I'm not a star by the time I'm 18
I'm going to have to
get out of the business.
I remember the studio exec looking at me
and his food almost
coming out of his mouth
and going "Vinnie, we're not even sure
we want to make this one,
how could you talk about three movies".
- He's an American
actor, producer, director
and screenwriter.
He's best known for his role as Dominic
in the Fast and the Furious series.
He made his stage debut at age seven
in the Dinosaur Door Play and
has been acting every since.
He's Vin Diesel and here's my take
on his top ten rules of success.
Rule number one is my personal favorite
and make sure to stick around
all the way til the end
for special bonus clips.
And as always, if Vin says something
that resinates with you, please leave it
in the comments below
and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired as well.
Enjoy.
(Swishing and loud beat)
(upbeat music)
- I, as you know, was a
bouncer for many years.
I remember coming home one
night after a big fight
and I run up to the kitchen, I get ice
and my hand's swollen and
just another day at work.
And I was feeling like, just bummed
about the fact that I was still doing
this job after all this time.
At that one moment I was like,
why are people--
why do people have so much anger?
Why do I have to, you know,
why is this my daily life,
to suppress everybody's anger
or check everybody's anger that comes into
the giant 3,000 person nightclub.
And my father, it was so simple,
but my father said "you know Vin,
I've traveled around the world.
I've been to India, I've been
to Russia, I've been to China.
I've been all through South America
and I've realized something".
I said "what".
He said "people, by and
large, are good people".
Sounded pretty simple
and yet it meant so much.
And if you look at my Facebook page,
or if you look at the way
that all that positive energy,
I don't think there's a page in the world
in history that harbors
as much positive energy
as one would see on this Facebook page.
- It's what you put out it.
- And it's really that.
- Right.
- And I say that because,
I say that because
if you believe that in your heart
and not everybody
watching this can say that
or is ready to say that or is comfortable
with themselves enough to say that,
but if you really believe in your heart
that people, by and large, are good people
it affects the way that
you address the world.
As you see, post in and post out,
I address a world that in my soul
I feel is comprised of good people.
My advice to people who
want to pursue their dream
is to find any way that
they can to make product.
My philosophy is that product
is the most important thing.
I started acting when
I was seven years old
and I didn't get paid as an actor
until I did Saving Private Ryan
and I was 30 at that time.
So, there were many, many years
of unemployment, obviously.
What I learned later was
that I had to have something.
I had to have product regardless
of how big or small it was
and the first thing that I did
was direct a short film
called Multi-Facial.
(dramatic music)
(exploding and falling rocks)
(music intensifying)
(cracking)
(dramatic music)
(swooshing as falling)
- No, Groot, you can't, you'll die.
Why are you doing this, why?
- We are Groot.
(dramatic music)
- So, Vin, voice of Groot and possibly
my favorite character in the film.
What were the difficulties of
kind of expressing yourself
with such limited vocabulary?
- Clearly the challenge
and clearly a challenge that a thespian
would never expect to be confronted with.
And yet, thank God that I
did have the opportunity
and the challenge to do it
because he is such a special character.
Yes, when Kevin Feige called me
he said "let me prefec this phone call
by telling that the character
we're about to discuss
is the strangest character Marvel
has ever attempted to
put on the big screen".
And then he said "however,
because Iron Giant
is a family favorite we believe
that you can bring life to this,
even though most people
will only hear you say
I am Groot".
And it was a shocker and
something very challenging
and something very interesting.
It was really my son,
my three year old son,
when I came home with the
book of conceptual art
and showed him all the
characters in the Galaxy,
he pointed to the tree
(laughing)
as a character that he thought was daddy.
- Everyone loves the tree,
everyone loves the tree.
(laughing)
- Sometimes you see someone
having enormous success
and there's just something about them,
you say good for him
and I think not just me,
but when I read about the response to you
lots of people are saying that.
Cheering for you to have the
accomplishments you have had.
- I feel that.
I've always felt the sense of support.
And I think that my struggle
to achieving this goal
and achieving this dream
is something that speaks volumes.
I started out acting at seven years old
and I struggled for so long.
There was a time in my life
when I said if I don't,
if I'm not a star by the time I'm 18,
I'm going to have to
get out of the business.
And then of course it jumped to 21
and then 25 and then I'm
looking in the mirror,
just past my mid 20s and I haven't,
I haven't received
health benefits from SAG.
And we all know that with
the Screen Actor's Guild
you got to make $7,000
in order to be eligible
for health benefits.
So, in fact, I didn't get health benefits
until I was 30 years old,
even while I was shooting
Saving Private Ryan
I wasn't covered.
(laughing)
And I think that that kind of rise to fame
is something that's empowering for people.
So, when they celebrate that story
I think that they are also celebrating
a, you know, a story that's about a guy
who was proactive and resourceful
and did pay his dues and
did struggle and persevered.
- And believed in himself?
- I think you have to.
I think the only thing
I had for so many years
was this confidence that
I held onto very tightly.
- Now, was it a difference
in confidence and arrogance?
- Oh, absolutely.
- You just knew that you were getting
the skills necessary to be good.
Then when moment came you'd
be ready and could deliver.
- Right.
I needed to be confident at
the risk even of being arrogant.
I needed to be confident
because I had nothing else.
And if you go into a situation where
you're dedicating your
whole life to something,
literally your whole life,
all of your decisions
are made with one common goal,
then I think that you'd
better believe in yourself.
Especially if you start to work,
to save money to make films.
I think you could ask
most people in the world
and they would tell you
that I'm not Hollywood
- [Interviewer] I know, I was speechless.
- I knew, but in a good way.
And it's not a bad question to ask because
it's not even so Hollywood.
How do you stay ground when
you have 90 million people
waiting for you to say something?
So, while I'm here right now,
and this will go out
to however many people,
at home, I know the second I hear "boom"
and my computer comes on,
there are 90 million people
waiting to hear something.
That's tricky.
How do you make sense of that?
What would Marlon Brando
have done if he could have,
would there have been a
sequel to On The Waterfront?
Maybe, if there was some
fan out in Texas that said
I can't wait to see
another On The Waterfront.
- [Interviewer] So do you
feel the pressure constantly
- Family--
- to deliver?
- I do feel pressure.
Family keeps you grounded because--
My toughest task is not going to be unlike
that other guy's toughest task.
The toughest task is to be
the best parent you can be.
We all share that, we all--
to be the best person you can be.
We're all growing as individuals.
We're all growing into our better selves.
Those are the things
that I stay focused on.
And I don't even know
if I'm that grounded.
I live in a fantasy world of scenes
in my head and future--
When I came here and I was about
to do Fast and Furious four,
they didn't think I was
grounded when I said
I can shoot three movies at the same time.
They thought I was insane
and they were like,
security, get him off the lot.
(laughing)
They never imagined it.
I remember the studio exec looking at me
and his food almost
coming out of his mouth
and going "Vinnie, we're not even sure
we want to make this one.
How could you talk about three movies?
Who cares what happens in five and six?"
And now the only thing they want to know
is what's going to happen after this.
How surreal.
- Incredible.
- It's incredible.
One of the interesting things
(coughing)
about the way that I did it was
or one of the interesting things about
being paid the amount of money
I'm being paid now for film
is back in 1996 I was
working to make movies.
So, whether I was saving $3,000,
putting a savings of $3,000 together,
which at the time was a feat.
- Yeah
- Or working the whole year telemarketing
to save $47,000, I was taking that money
and investing it in my career
and investing in something
that I believed in.
- How do you invest in your career?
- Well,
- At that stage.
- At that stage, if people
aren't offering you roles.
The interesting thing
about being an actor,
it's different than the other art mediums.
If you're an actor you're
dependent upon on a director,
a screenwriter, a producer,
a studio to fund it,
a studio to market the film.
Even after I made Strays, I didn't have--
and I went to dramatic
competition at Sundance,
I didn't have a distributor.
So, I could only make the film
and thank God there was a forum.
Thank God Robert Redford
had put together a forum
for these films to be shown.
And even then, even
after you make the film
and you put the film in the can,
you still have to have somebody come along
and spend money to distribute the film.
So, as an actor, you need all these
external factors to be artistic.
If you're a musician you could, you know,
woodshed and make music.
If you're a painter
- You could do it alone.
And being an actor is
a lot less autonomous.
So, I needed to find a way to
fulfill all those other positions.
I had to learn how to write screenplays.
So I went to college and
learned how to write screenplays
and I was horrible in
english in high school
and became an english major in college.
I started directing and
learning how to direct.
And learning really
about the film business
which is probably the number one thing
that separates the unemployed
Vin and the employed Vin.
It was the understanding of Hollywood
and the understanding of the business
and the understanding of strategy.
Because so many years I was
just concerned with the craft
and all I thought about was how to make
the craft as good as possible.
I've been acting since
I was seven years old
so that's always been a comfort zone.
People would often ask me
what do I enjoy doing more,
acting or directing, 'cause I started
my career as a director.
And I would say directing offers me
the opportunity to tell a story.
Acting is more of a
therapeutic process for me
because as a kid I was
always, like most kids,
curious about my identity,
in search of my identity.
And when you play a character
the parameters of that character
and that identity are clear.
There's something therapeutic about that.
There's no guessing games
when you fall into character.
So, if I'm not in character
and I'm usually in character,
unlike other actors that can turn it off
when the director says cut,
I've never had that ability.
I'm usually somewhat in the character
even after the director says cut.
- If you could talk to your younger self,
knowing what you know, in those days
when you thought maybe
it's not going to happen,
what would you tell yourself?
- Play it cool.
I'd say, I'd say play it cool
and learn as much as you can
because everything you
learn you're going to need.
You won't have enough time to learn.
Everything is an education.
- I see that the way you use social media,
the way you reach out to your fans,
and there is a very direct approach
that you utilize.
- Yeah.
- And some people don't do that
and some people can't do that,
but I think it, for you, really embodies
who you are as a person
and when you meet people.
Embracing something like that,
is that ever scary for you or
is it just, look, these are the people
that want to buy your tickets
and you'd love to talk back to them?
- I think you have to be, I
think there's something scary
about talking to a group
of people anywhere.
If you walk up on stage at Comic-Con,
you, yourself, you can
feel, we all feel that,
that little bit of anxiety before
speaking to a body of people.
So, it's no different on Facebook.
So, if you're, when you sit down,
there are times I could sit down
to write a post and be at that
chair for two or three hours
and scrap the whole post
and not put anything up
because you do want to be thoughtful
about what you're saying,
even if what you're saying
is something kind of trite
or seemingly insignificant.
As everybody on the page knows,
there's always something cryptic
behind every damn thing I say.
And I embraced it differently
than I think other people have
or looked at it differently
than other people did early on,
when, you know, no one had a million fans
and it was brand new and
Obama had just gotten elected
and he used the social
media platform to do that
and it was still new.
I looked at it as an opportunity
to for the first time in my life,
be able to hear the audiences
thought-out reaction to my work
or whatever film I had done,
or characters that I might not have done,
for example Riddick.
And so, I feel like if I
didn't have that social media,
I don't think I would have ever
been pushed to make
Riddick at the same level.
It was the audience saying,
I remember this one
comment on a Riddick post
where, and this was years
before we ever made the movie,
when it was still kind
of, we were uncertain
if we'd ever have the
rights to make the movie
and someone said "hey,
Vin, there really needs
to be another Riddick
and we're really happy
that you're doing Fast,
but we need another Riddick
and I'm sure that if
all of us gave you $10,
you could surely get the money
to make it then rated
R, the way you want to".
And this was before
Kickstarter and all that stuff
and there was something
so endearing about that
and that sentiment that
I felt even if I have
to go make this movie for free,
I've got to go make this movie.
It's something that has resinated
and sometimes the audience,
the film-going audience,
vetoes the studio and in this situation
that's exactly what happened.
The studio initially, the last decade,
didn't think, didn't know whether they
were going to be able to revisit this
at the high level and
still maintain that rated R
and it might not have been made,
but it was that audience that said
it has to be made and that's how we--
Back in 2002, it was you, the MTV audience
that first acknowledged this brotherhood
between Paul Walker and myself
by honoring us with the Best Team on Film.
So, it's surreal to be
standing here 12 years later
and that you have been so generous
to give us this award again.
I wish he could be here to see this,
but I know he's here in spirit.
Thank you for honoring
me and more importantly,
thank you for honoring that angel,
my brother, Paul Walker.
- Thank you so much for watching.
I made this video because
C.J. Jones asked me to.
So, if there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next, leave it
in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do.
I'm also curious to know which one
of Vin Diesel's top ten rules had
the biggest impact on you and why.
What did you learn from it,
what are you going to apply
to your life or your business?
Leave it in the comments, I'm
going to join in the discussion.
Finally, I want to give a
quick shout out to Sadaf Virji.
Sadaf, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book
and taking that picture
and posting it on Facebook.
It really means a lot to
me and I hope you enjoy it
and find your one word.
So, thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you, I hope you continue
to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see ya soon.
- So, Vin, I've heard you're really
into Dungeons and Dragons.
(audience wooing)
So, I have two questions.
- Yes.
- What character do you play
and would you be willing
to join our group?
(laughing)
- You know, it's whenever
anyone asks me to join
their campaign, there's
a good old feeling I have
where I feel like, you know,
I'm not alone in the world.
(laughing)
And it's okay to be a dweeb.
I played a lot of characters and I played,
my most famous character
you might have read about,
which was my witch hunter,
my half-drow witch hunter.
The irony is I'm about to next month
do a movie called The Witch Hunter.
Kind of freaky.
(laughing)
I mean, I never thought
in a million years,
when I was rolling the 20-sided
die 20 something years ago
that Hollywood would make a
movie about a witch hunter,
but that's another story.
(laughing)
Where are you playing
in, on the east coast?
- Well, we actually do it over video chat.
- You are doing video chat.
- Yeah.
So, we've got one guy
down in North Carolina
and he will video in.
- Are you using modules, I mean--
(laughing)
- It's mostly second edition rules,
but they have some holdovers
from the first edition, so.
- Okay, okay.
- He's thinking about it.
- I mean, we played with everything.
That's were the witch hunter,
witch hunter wasn't created
by Gary Gygax, as you know.
It was the aftermarket books,
that we were trying to incorporate
and create new games and trying to create.
It was a special time.
(laughing)
D & D was a special time.
Yeah, man, we might have to get into that.
We might have to get into that.
I could get into that, man.
(laughing)
Did you know that Gary Gygax--
I'm sorry, guys.
- I told you it was
going to get dorky, yeah.
- Let's split up into breakout sessions
where everyone gets their
own Guardian of the Galaxy.
- Well, I'll tell ya
later, it's Gary Gygax, so.
The movie opens up tonight
at midnight in America, so.
- [Interviewer] How do
you explain the success?
All over the world, I mean.
In Australian and in the U.K.
- Well, I have a Facebook page.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, I know.
- Almost 23 million people.
- Yeah.
- That doesn't hurt.
But I think the audience
really appreciates
the integrity that goes into this film.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- So many action films of
this size are gratuitous
and don't take the time to work out story
and character and add heart,
and feeling and emotion and romance.
I think that's what elevates this movie.
I think this movie, if you didn't see it
and if you didn't see the last one,
you could write it off
as just an action movie.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- But I think that, the fact
that it's deeper than that,
and the fact that it's multi-cultural.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- No action movie has subtitles
of people talking in spanish.
- Yeah.
- But that's, or Portuguese,
but that says something
about what kind of franchise this is.
(motor running)
- You got some serious balls, man.
- I've been told.
- You know, you're lucky I missed my shot.
- I think you hit your mark.
- Really?
What is it with you?
What'd you got, a death wish or something?
- If that's what it takes.
I just want to race.
- You might lose your car.
(chuckling)
- Let's do it.
- Your funeral.
- Ride or die, remember?
(upbeat music)